Hello everyone, this is
Dr. Carl Lamer-Hamm giving
this lecture on opportunistic
infections in adults.
I hope everyone's had a
great day so far and are
ready to delve into this
very interesting subject.
So by the time we're
done with this lecture
today, you should be able
to discuss the various
mechanisms of acquired
immune deficiency,
gauge the type and severity
of immune deficiency in
a patient presenting with
opportunistic infection,
differentiate opportunistic
pathogens that may present
in patients with immune
deficiency diagnose treat
and manage a patient with
severe immune deficiency
secondary to aids identify
the risk factors for
immune reconstitution
inflammatory syndrome here is the
required and optional
reading the optional reading
is truly optional it's
only if you have some extra
time It is very, very dense,
and I do not think you
should be reading this if
you're strapped for time.
Let's talk a little bit about
the design of this lecture.
First, we're going to talk
about some definitions.
Then we're going to go
over the opportunistic
infections that occur in
hematopoietic, solid organ
transplant, and those
who receive myeloablative
chemotherapy. Then we'll
use a patient living
with HIV and AIDS as an
example of what sort of
opportunistic infections
occur in that patient
population, and we'll go
over each one of those
opportunistic organisms
one at a time by necessity.
We're only going to be
able to go through a few
things here, and there
is no way to completely
cover this vast subject
in this single lecture.
You're going to have to
research this subject on
your own in order to
fill in some of the gaps.
Most of the slides, if not
all of them, are single
concepts that you can stop
and start the video or
begin the narration if you're
using just the PowerPoint
presentation and then
stop it at the end of the
slide and just take some
notes, make some flashcards,
and just think about the
subject just a little
bit. And there are several
points throughout this
lecture during which
I ask you to pause and
think. So go ahead and
just stop the video or hold
up on the PowerPoint
at that point and think
about what the questions
are. Let's get started.
So just what is immune
deficiency? I know we all think
about patients who receive
chemotherapy and lose
their hair and their immune
systems are tanked or those
who receive organ transplantation
or persons who are
living with advanced AIDS
who are not on therapy as
the classic examples of
immune deficiency. But I don't
want us to be pigeonholed
into just those concepts.
Remember, we have lots of
different parts of our immune
system, and any time parts
of those immune systems
don't work or are breached,
for example, our skin,
we can be immune deficient.
For example, someone
who has a significant
burn over much of their
skin is very immune
deficient. So any time that
there is a breach of a
natural barrier, skin,
mucosa, any time someone
has lost their spleen.
And one of the examples
that people very frequently
forget are chronic administration
of corticosteroids.
corticosteroids can be
very immune suppressing
and they are not
benign medications
several years ago a danish
study showed that even a
single dose of a corticosteroid
can increase the risk
of acquiring mrsa colonization
so think about that
when people are prescribed
prednisone for upper
respiratory tract infections
or sinus infections and the
like but classically we do
think about those who receive
myeloblative chemotherapy
receive some sort of
transplant or advanced aids
as the prime examples of
immune deficiency and in
these states People can be
infected with not only the
usual organisms, such as
Staphylococcus aureus and
Pseudomonas aeruginosa, but
also what we term opportunistic
pathogens, including
saprophytes. And these
infections may actually be newly
acquired, or they may come
from our own commensal
flora, or occur due to
reactivation of a prior
infection, such as ******
simplex or latent tuberculosis.
What is an opportunistic
infection? This is an infection
that does not typically
occur in a person who
has an intact immune system.
When the skin barrier is
breached, for example, when
we put in a central venous
catheter through the skin
into the vein, we can
get infections with even our
own skin bacteria, mostly
Staphylococcus epidermidis,
sometimes Staphylococcus
aureus, as some people do
carry Staphylococcus aureus
on their skin if we give
people antibiotics they
can have a gut microbiome
imbalance and that can
result in a clostridium
difficile infection sometimes
people take probiotics to
try and ward off the bad
effects of antibiotics in
the gi system but if you have
just received a stem cell
transplant and inadvertently
take probiotics so you
could actually become septic
with the lactobacillus
that is in that preparation
there are organisms that
come from tap water such
as mycobacterium avium
which occurs in persons with
advanced aids or those with
structural lung disease.
People with burns
are very susceptible
to Pseudomonas
aeruginosa infections.
Examples of opportunistic
infections that occur
by reactivation include
the ****** viruses,
Toxoplasma, and
Mycobacterium tuberculosis.
For example, on the
bottom left is an MRI of a
patient who presented
with Horner's syndrome
that turned out to be
secondary to a reactivation
of toxoplasma in the
left basal ganglia.
Let's review some of the states
in which immune
deficiency occurs.
Those who are at
the extremes of age
are at increased
risk of infection.
Neonates do not have an
immune system of their own,
and those who are elderly
have waning of the immune
system and this can be
represented by the appearance
of ****** zoster as the
immunity to varicella zoster
virus wanes with age.
Those who receive broad
spectrum antibiotic therapy,
for example those who have
sepsis or are being treated
for antibiotic resistant
organisms that necessitates
very broad antibiotic
therapy are at risk for
other antibiotic resistant
organism infections such
as Pseudomonas and Candida.
Anytime a foreign body
is implanted, that
foreign body is at risk
of becoming infected
because it has no
blood supply or immune
system of its own, and
that person with that
foreign body is therefore
immune-suppressed.
Examples include central
venous catheters,
urinary catheters in the
bladder, joint replacements,
heart valve replacements,
and pacemakers.
And the most common organisms
include Staphylococcus
epidermidis,
Staphylococcus
aureus, Enterococci,
Carinibacterium, and Candida.
Carinibacterium in particular
has become a common
infection in those with
ventriculoperitoneal shunts.
We've mentioned breaching
the skin barrier and that
happens anytime there is
trauma to the skin such
as burns, but also
penetrating injuries such as
knife wounds and wounds
that occur on the job site,
especially in construction,
and also after surgery.
A surgical wound is
at risk of becoming
infected, and that puts
that person at risk.
Persons with
chronic illness, for
example, diabetes,
chronic renal failure,
COPD, cystic fibrosis,
chronic systolic heart
failure, are all at increased
risk of being infected.
For example, a person
with type 2 diabetes has
at least a twice times risk
of infection compared to
those without diabetes.
A more classical form
of immune suppression
includes complement
deficiencies. For example,
persons with SLE, they
are at increased risk of
having infections secondary
to Neisseria species.
And we can knock
out the terminal
complement components
with medications.
Eculizumab is a monoclonal
antibody directed
toward the terminal
complement component C5.
Persons taking this
medication are also
at increased risk of
Neisseria infection.
Monoclonal antibodies
have revolutionized the
treatment for some diseases,
especially autoimmune
disease, but they are
not without their risks.
Natalizumab is an antibody
against alpha-4-integrin,
and it was used to treat
persons with multiple
sclerosis. It was very
effective. However, it
had the rare side effect
of reactivation of
progressive multifocal
leukoencephalopathy, something
that we'll look out in
detail a little bit later.
This resulted in its being
taken off the market.
Now let's talk about some
of the more classical
forms of immune deficiency.
You've had a lecture
on pediatric immune
deficiency, so we won't be
talking about the congenital
forms in this lecture.
But acquired forms can
include things like humoral
deficiency secondary
to multiple myeloma,
chronic lymphocytic
leukemia, small lymphocyte
lymphoma, and splenectomy.
Those with humoral deficiency
are at increased risk of
Haemophilus influenzae,
Neisseria meningitidis,
Streptococcus
pneumoniae, and capnocytophagia
infections, as well
as parasitic infections
secondary to babesiosis.
Granulosa utopinia
is also an immune
deficiency that
increases the risk
of infection with
certain organisms.
This occurs in those
with hematopoietic
stem cell transplantation,
myelosuppressive chemotherapy,
and acute leukemia,
and the organisms
we worry about in
these cases include
the gram-negative
enterics, pseudomonas,
staphylococcus aureus,
and epidermidis,
viridans streptococci,
candida, aspergillus,
trichosporon, scutosporium,
fusarium, and
mucormycosis. Defects in
cellular immunity occur in
those with lymphoreticular
malignancies, those
taking corticosteroids,
cyclosporine and
tacrolimus given for immune
rejection prevention, those
with solid organ transplants,
those taking TNF
inhibitors and an illness
called idiopathic CD4
lymphopenia, which mimics the
immune deficiency seen
in those who are living
with advanced AIDS, but
are not infected with HIV.
Organisms infecting persons
in this category include
Listeria, Legionella,
Salmonella, Mycobacterium,
and the viruses HSV,
Varicella zoster virus,
cytomegalovirus, EBV,
hepatitis viruses B and C,
the fungi cryptococci,
coccidioides, histoplasma,
and pneumocystis,
and the parasite
toxoplasma. I've also
listed HIV infection
in this category.
Usually, we are talking about
those who are living with
advanced AIDS, and those
persons actually have a mixed
deficiency of both the
humeral and cellular arms,
putting them at increased
risk for infection by any of
the organisms in both
categories of immune deficiency.
Time course has a lot to
do with infection risk in
those after transplantation.
In those after stem cell
transplant, there is an
early post-transplant period,
the pre-engraftment phase
that occurs within the
first three weeks. These
persons have severe neutropenia
during this period, so
they are at risk for
infection secondary to
staphylococci, gram negatives,
****** simplex,
respiratory syncytial
virus, candida,
and aspergillus.
From three weeks to three
months, the post-engrasment
phase, they are at
increased risk of infection
with cytomegalovirus,
adenovirus, aspergillus,
candida, and pneumocystis.
beyond three months they
remain at increased risk
of varicella zoster virus
aspergillus and
cytomegalovirus infection these
risks primarily pertain
to those who receive an
allogeneic stem cell transplant
the risks are much lower
for those who receive
syngenaic transplants that
time course concept also
applies to those after solid
organ transplantation
immediate post-operative
infections usually involve
the transplanted organ. Two
to four weeks after the
transplant there are infections
with wounds, intravenous
catheters, or urinary
tract infections secondary
to Foley catheters in the
bladder. And there are
infections of the transplanted
organs. For example,
pneumonia in lung transplants,
urinary tract infections,
renal or perinephric
abscesses in kidney
transplants, and myocarditis
in heart transplants.
One to six months
post-transplant,
the immune suppressive
medications are the main
risk for infection.
And during this period,
we see reactivation
secondary to ****** simplex,
varicella, and
cytomegalovirus, as well as
infection secondary to
candida, aspergillus,
cryptococcus, pneumocystis,
listeria, neocardia, and
toxoplasma. You will notice
that these organisms are
those that occur when there
is cell-mediated immune
deficiency. CMV infection
can also be derived from the
donor transplant and those
persons who have never been
infected with CMV before and
are CMV antibody negative
are those who are most at
risk for becoming infected
with CMV if their donor had
CMV infection. in other words
the donor was cmv antibody
positive those with the
lowest risk are those who
have never had cmv who receive
a transplant from a donor
who is also never infected
with cmv in the past and
those at intermediate risk
are listed in the above table
This is relevant because
those who are at highest
risk for CMV infection after
solid organ transplantation
are at very high risk of
the organ failing secondary
to the infection and are
given valgancyclovir for
prophylaxis against infection.
Lastly, I want to make
sure that it's clear that
these infections in both
hematopoietic stem cell
transplants and solid organ
transplants are not trivial.
These infections do not
only put the patient at
high risk for morbidity and
mortality, but each infection
increases the risk of
losing the graft or failure
of transplanted stem cells
to function. And both
of those scenarios are
disasters for the patient.
Next, let's talk about
those with granulocytopenia.
These are mostly patients
who have a myeloablative
chemotherapy, but also some
patients with acute leukemia and
other conditions can have
severe granulocytopenia.
Many of these patients may
have had irradiation, which
also can depress bone marrow
function and exacerbate
the granulocytopenia, as well
as cause other cytopenias.
These patients have mucosal
barrier damage. They are
at risk of infection secondary
to oral and gut organisms.
They also have infections
secondary to skin organisms
such as coagulase negative
staphylococci, staphylococcus
epidermidis being the
usual pathogen in that
group, but there are others,
as well as staphylococcus
aureus. From the oral cavity,
there are the oral anaerobes
and streptococcus viridans.
From the gut originates
the enteric gram negatives,
as well as the gut
anaerobes, usually becteroides,
as well as enterococci and
pseudomonas aeruginosa. We
classify neutropenia as severe
when the granulocyte count
falls below 500 per mil.
The risk increases a little
bit when the count falls
below 1,000, but the very
highest risk patients are
those who have counts less
than 100, especially if the
duration of neutropenia lasts
greater than seven days.
Persons living with
advanced untreated AIDS are
models of immune suppression
secondary to both
humoral and cell-mediated
deficiency. We met Bobby
during the lecture on HIV
and retroviruses and I
told you that he would
be back in this lecture.
Briefly, he was diagnosed
with HIV and AIDS many
years ago and was placed
on antiretroviral therapy
and did very well. But
he became lost to follow
-up. And now he presents
with fever, cough, and
shortness of breath. He
reports that three weeks
ago, he had the onset of
progressively worsening
cough that was accompanied
at first by low-grade
fever and then high fever
of 39.4 degrees Celsius.
This was accompanied
by shaking chills,
and for the last one
and a half weeks, he's
had progressive
shortness of breath, at
first only on exertion
and now at rest.
And he explains that
the reason he was
lost a follow-up, that
eight years ago he
broke up with his
partner of four years.
and returned to using
injection drugs, mostly ******.
He stopped taking
antiretroviral therapy then
and over the last year
has been feeling unwell.
He has lost 35 pounds
and was hospitalized
8 months ago for 5
days with pneumonia.
He has not otherwise
seen a physician
since he last saw
you 8 years ago.
bobby's exam is significant
for a thin male being in
respiratory distress unable
to finish full sentences
his vital signs are as
listed he had no rash there
was a white cottage cheese
like exudate that was
easily scraped off the
buccal mucosa he had shoddy
axillary adenopathy his
lung fields were clear and
percussion was normal. He
had thoracic paraspina skin
drag that was prolonged at
T1 through T4 bilaterally.
Bobby is admitted
to the ICU and
placed on mechanical
ventilation.
CBC shows pancytopenia
and the chest x-ray showed
bilateral interstitial
and ground glass
opacities without effusions.
A procedure is done.
So Bobby's in trouble and
this is our first pause
slide. What labs would you
order? What procedure do you
think was done and what
antibiotics would you start?
And at this point I would
just like to say that this
is not an unusual way for
someone with immune deficiency
to present. Sometimes
those with severe immune
deficiency can present with
a chronic illness such as
progressive mental slowing
or a neurologic deficit.
For example, in persons
who are on natalizumab who
acquire progressive multifocal
leukoencephalopathy. But
patients who are absolutely
neutropenic, especially if
the granulocyte counts are
less than 100 or have very
severe cell-mediated or
humoral deficiency can
present with an acute illness
such as sepsis and be dead
within hours. Never take
for granted how fast these
patients can become critically
ill. Okay, hit pause,
think about it a little bit,
and then we'll continue.
Now you should remember from
the lecture on HIV about
the time course of untreated
HIV infection, and as
the CD4 count drops below
200, there is precipitous
failure of both cell-mediated
and humoral arms of the
immune system. But even
before that, persons living
with HIV are at increased
risk of certain infections
when their CD4 counts are
higher. For example, at
less than 500, there is
increased incidence of oral
thrush, oral hairy
leukoplakia, secondary to EBV,
Bartonella henselae infections,
and infections with human
****** virus 8 and human
papillomavirus. We know
that once they hit the CD4
count of 200 or below, they're
at increased risk for
pneumocystis, histoplasma,
and PML. Less than 100, they
are at risk for cerebral
toxoplasmosis, infection
secondary to aspergillus,
cryptosporidium, and of B-cell
lymphoma secondary to EBV.
And at less than 50,
there is increased risk
of cryptococcal
meningitis, CMV retinitis,
esophageal candidiasis, and
disseminated mycobacterium
avium intracellulare.
During that lecture,
we also listed some
of the AIDS-defining
conditions, as well as
linked to a complete table.
It is important to note
that while this is important
for statistical purposes
and to prognosticate
patients who are severely
ill, this is in no way a
death sentence as it was
in the 80s and early 90s.
Patients who are very ill
with very low CD4 counts
can be treated and given
antiretrovirals, become
healthy, and live very long
lives. The AIDS diagnosis
can be very alarming to
patients, and the stigma
from the 1980s and early
1990s still exists. It
is important to point out
to those patients that a
diagnosis of AIDS is not
a death sentence, and with
good treatment, the
expectation is a long life.
So for Bobby, the
differential diagnosis is
broad. In those with
severe combined immune
deficiency and are
critically ill with ground
glass pulmonary opacities,
The differential
diagnosis includes
pneumocystis, tuberculosis,
streptococcus pneumoniae,
and staphylococcus
aureus, including
MRSA, pseudomonas,
influenza,
HSV, CMV,
varicella zoster,
histoplasma, coccidioides,
pulmonary lymphoma with
lymphangetic spread,
acute pulmonary edema,
and ARDS. I list all these
not so that you have to
memorize them here, just so
you understand that the
differential is very broad.
Let's talk about
a few of these.
Pneumocystis urovicii used to
be called Pneumocystis carinii.
This is a ****** that
causes widespread
asymptomatic
infection in mammals.
It colonizes the lungs.
It's not a commensal.
transmission occurs from
person to person via
inhalation. The risk is cell
-mediated immune deficiency,
and this is the most
common opportunistic
infection for which persons
who are living with HIV
and are untreated present
with. It also occurs in
persons who are treated
with prolonged steroids.
Usually, persons have a CD4
count less than 200 if they
are living with HIV. They
have subacute pulmonary
symptoms beginning with a
non-productive cough followed
by fever and progressively
worsening shortness of
breath. This is one of those
atypical pneumonias but it
causes very severe disease.
The lung exam is usually
quiet. In other words, the
findings on exam are much less
than would be expected for
the severity of disease.
The chest x-ray shows
bilateral interstitial ground
glass opacities as is shown
on the figure at the right
and effusions are very
rare. It's diagnosed by
methamphetamine silver stain
as shown in the figure up top.
tissue PCR or antigen testing
of saliva or bronchoalveolar
lavage. The pathology
shows foamy macrophages.
That's a buzzword right
there. And you can also do the
beta-D-glucan test in blood,
which should be positive.
Persons with pneumocystis
pneumonia have very
high LDH in the blood.
And that is a clue.
Treatment is with
trimethyrum sulfamethoxazole.
And in severe cases,
prednisone must be given
in order to decrease the
pulmonary inflammation.
In those with sulfamethoxazole
allergy, you can give
pentamidine, although that's
a difficult drug to give.
And in mild to moderate
disease in outpatients, for
those with allergy, you can
give a tovacone or dapsone.
Prophylaxis, when the
CD4 falls less than
200, is usually trimethrobum
sulfamethoxazole
or dapsone in those
who are allergic.
Cytomegalovirus is a beta
****** viridae. It is usually
acquired in childhood and
results in lifelong latent
infection. In those with cell
-mediated immune deficiency
and low cd4 count there
is reactivation disease
and we talked about the risk
of cytomegalovirus in solid
organ transplant the elderly
are also at risk and this
usually presents as cmv
colitis patients usually
present with a cd4 count
of less than 50 those with
retinitis experience visual
loss, floaters, and flashing
lights. Those with pneumonitis
have pulmonary symptoms.
Those with ulcerative
esophagitis have
odinophagia, and those
with colitis have diarrhea.
Again, infection with CMV is
a risk for transplant failure.
On exam, you will see flame
hemorrhages and cotton
wool spots in the retina.
On EGD this causes very
distinct long deep linear
ulcers and on chest x-ray
there is bilateral ground
glass opacities usually
without effusion. The
diseases diagnosed clinically
by retinal exam or blood
or tissue PCR and tissue
biopsy shows the typical
owl's eye inclusion bodies.
An example is shown at the
bottom right. Atop that
is an esophageal ulcer and
at the top are examples
of cotton wool spots in
the retina. Treatment is
with ganciclovir IV. If
it is severe, the retinal
disease inquires
intravitreal injections. Mild
disease may be treated
with valgancyclovir, and if
there is resistance to
those medications, cytofavir
or foscarnid is used,
although these drugs are much
more difficult to use
secondary to side effects.
Secondary prophylaxis
for those who have
been treated is
valgancyclovir ******.
****** simplex virus is
an alpha ****** viridae.
Transmission usually occurs
during or after childhood and
results in lifelong latent
infection. In those with
cell-mediated immune deficiency
or in the elderly with
waning immune memory,
patients may present with
retinitis, with visual loss,
painful chronic oral ulcers,
esophagitis,
tracheobronchitis, pneumonitis,
colitis, and encephalitis.
The retinal exam is different
than in CMV in that it shows
pale peripheral lesions
with central necrosis. On
the very right there is an
EGD where the esophageal
ulcers due to HSV are sort
of these crops that are very
shallow. Again very different
than in cmv which is the
long deep linear ulcer
ct of the chest and those
with pneumonitis shows ground
glass opacities and that is
shown at the bottom right
brain lesions are usually of
the temporal lobe as shown
in the mri at the right
on the left and diagnosis
is usually done by PCR of
an ulcer, tissue biopsy, or
cerebrospinal fluid. Tissue
biopsies can also show the
multinucleotegiate
cells on the Tzank
test, and that is
shown up top. Treatment
is with IV acyclovir
in severe cases,
oral acyclovir in mild
cases, and if there
is resistance, foscarnet.
Alternatives to
acyclovir include
famcyclovir and valacyclovir.
Valacyclovir has the
advantage of having
greater bioavailability
and secondary or
primary prophylaxis is
given with acyclovir.
The last pathogen we'll talk
about in this section is
varicella zoster virus.
This is also an alpha ******
viridae. It's the agent of
chickenpox and also ******
zoster. Transmission usually
occurs during childhood
in those who are unvaccinated
and again results in latent
lifelong infection. In
those with cell-mediated
immune deficiency, for example,
in those living with HIV
with a CD4 count less than
200 or those less than 50
get retinitis or acute
retinal necrosis respectively.
The latter is an emergent
condition that results in
acute visual loss if not
treated aggressively. it can
also cause pneumonitis and
encephalitis retinal exam
will show diffuse flame
hemorrhages that's shown
at the bottom right
pneumonitis is characterized by
nodular densities with surrounding
ground glass attenuation
that is shown up top
the diagnosis is made by
pcr pcr of tissue ulcer
base or cerebrospinal fluid
and tissue biopsies again
can show the giant cells by
zank test treatment is
acyclovir famcyclovir or
valacyclovir and prophylaxis
can be given with acyclovir
don't forget there's the
vaccine including that for
zoster and the immune
globulin is usually reserved
for those with exposure for
example during pregnancy
bobby was started on
intravenous trimethoprim
sulfamethoxazole given prednisone
and intravenous vancomycin
and meropenem that
was for the pneumonia
fluconazole was begun for oral
candidiasis his laboratories
showed a cd4 count of three
a viral load of greater
than one million and ldh
almost 1000 and uh blood
cultures a beta-d-glucan
and cmvp or pcr that were
all negative. He was
pancytopenic, had elevated
transaminases, and was in
acute renal insufficiency.
A sputum bitracheal
suction was positive for
pneumocystis antigen,
and that shows that
the beta-D-glucan can
sometimes be negative
even in patients infected
with pneumocystis.
But usually, the beta-D
-glucan serum test is positive.
And the procedure? A
bronchoscopy with a bronchial
biopsy. It showed
foamy macrophages and
methenamine silver stain
showed pneumocystis-like
organisms. That is a
diagnosis for pneumocystis.
Bacterial and fungal
cultures and a respiratory
viral panel of lavage
fluid were all negative.
vancomycin and miropenem
were discontinued his
oxygenation improved and he
was eventually extubated his
ldh normalized and on
hospital day he transferred
out of the unit on hospital
day eight he complained
of severe odinophagia
oral examination revealed
resolution of the oral
candidiasis what do you think
was his next procedure
let's pause here and think
about it When you're ready,
go on to the next slide.
Esophagogastroduodenoscopy
showed long, deep,
linear ulcerations
in the mid-esophagus.
Go ahead and pause again
here and remember which
organism caused this
characteristic lesion.
Was it HSV, CMV, or candida? Of
the many different
organisms that can cause
esophagitis, the three most
common are candida species,
CMV, and HSV. Of the
candida species that
cause esophagitis,
albicans is by far the most
common. The appearance
is large mucoid
colonies that have a
cottage cheese appearance.
The colonies that are lining
the esophagus in panel A
above are typical. Candida
is easily seen on gram stain
and the conformation can
come both with germ tube
and culture. The treatment is
high dose fluconazole which
can be taken ****** if
the patient tolerates but
can also be given intravenously
if they're not able to
take anything by mouth because
of the esophagitis. CMV
esophagitis is characterized
by long deep linear ulcers.
You can see in panel B
above how deep and large
that ulcer is. Zank smear
or PCR will give you the
diagnosis and the treatment is
usually intravenous ganciclovir,
which can be switched to
valgancyclovir when there
is improvement and then
the patient remains on
valgancyclovir indefinitely
for secondary prophylaxis.
****** simplex virus esophagitis
is characterized by crops
of shallow ulcers as
exemplified by panel c above
and zank or pcr is positive
the treatment is valacyclovir
acyclovir iv or acyclovir
by mouth back to bobby
the cmv pcr of the esophageal
ulcer is positive and iv
ganciclovir is begun His
eudinophagia improves, but
three days later on hospital
day 12, he has new chills
associated with diaphoresis
and tachycardia. He doesn't
have any fever. He also
has noted mild axillary
submental and inguinal adenopathy.
His pancytopenia, despite
his clinical improvement
before, has persisted.
Alkaline phosphatase has
increased to four times normal.
Mycobacterial sputum and
blood cultures obtained
on admission are reported
from the lab to be growing
an organism and guess what
a procedure is performed
go ahead and pause here
and i'd like you to
think about what procedure
you think was performed
and also i'd like you to
comment on why you think
there was no fever at this
point especially when we
go into what the diagnosis
is we will talk about
that point specifically
during office hours Bobby
has disseminated Mycobacterium
avium intracellulari.
These are actually two
different species of rapidly
growing non-tuberculous
mycobacteria, but testing does
not usually differentiate
between the two of them.
So you will see them reported
out this way. This is a
ubiquitous waterborne
organism. It used to be very
common in persons living with
AIDS when CD4 counts were
less than 50. We don't see
this very much anymore.
Patients would
present with fever,
weight loss, diarrhea,
lymphadenopathy,
elevated serum alkaline
phosphatase, and cytopenias,
especially anemia. The
diagnosis is made by doing a
special blood culture, a
mycobacterial blood culture, and
the organism can also be
isolated in tissues by bone
marrow biopsy, PCR, and also
by doing a modified acid
fast called a Zeal-Nielsen
stain. Treatment is with
chlorothromycin or azithromycin
in combination with ethambutol.
It's very important to test
for macrolide resistance,
and if present, add another
drug that is effective.
There are several, because
ethambutol monotherapy
usually ends up failing. We
used to give azithromycin for
prophylaxis for this organism
whenever the CD4 count
was less than 100. But since
this is now so uncommon,
prophylaxis is no longer given.
Essentially,
antiretroviral therapy
has been so effective
that no one's
really getting this
anymore, at least not
those living with HIV.
Lady Windermere syndrome
is pulmonary mycobacterium
avium disease that
occurs in thin, elderly
women with no known
medical illness or risk
factor. Until recently,
the cause was unknown,
but a genetic defect
has been found to be
associated with this illness
and may be the reason.
Bobby has a bone
marrow biopsy done
that shows organisms
on Zeal Nelson.
Staining and sputum PCR
is positive for MII.
Trimethoprim sulfamethoxazole,
prednisone, valgancyclovir
are continued. On hospital
day 16, he complains of
a vague headache that
may have been present for
several days, but today is
severe enough to be bothersome
and he notes mild to
moderate neck stiffness.
Go ahead and pause again.
What procedure do you
think was performed next?
Headache and meningitis
suggest meningitis and there
is a specific diagnosis
in persons who are living
with AIDS with very low
CD4 counts. This includes
cryptococcus neophormans,
histoplasma capsulatum,
coccidioides imidus,
mycobacterium tuberculosis,
********, lysteria,
lymphomatous meningitis,
and aseptic meningitis.
Bobby is actually
on a medication that
can cause aseptic
meningitis. However,
this is an infectious
meningitis.
Those with meningitis
usually present with
headache, fever, photophobia,
and neck stiffness.
However, cryptococcus
neophormans may actually
be asymptomatic in the
nervous system for quite
some time. In persons
living with AIDS, possibly
secondary to a decreased
inflammatory response.
Because meningitis is
inflammation of the
meninges, there usually
isn't parenchymal
involvement and no change
in level of consciousness.
However, altered mental
status usually indicates
increased intracranial pressure,
which increases the risk
for uncle herniation, which
is life-threatening. The
diagnosis for meningitis is
usually by lumbar puncture.
Cryptococcus is a yeast
-like ****** that is derived
from the soil that's
contaminated with avian droppings
in the case of neophormans
or with arboreal species
in the case of the species
gadii. Patients who are
living with age usually have
a CD4 count less than 50.
Also, patients with
hematologic malignancies, solid
organ transplants, or on
long-term corticosteroids are
at risk. It is the most
common cause of meningitis in
persons living with AIDS.
The transmission is through
the inhalation of yeasts
that were in soil, and these
somehow go from the lungs
to the meninges. The capsule
is antiphagocytic, and the
capsular polysaccharide
actively evades the immune
response. Patients present with
fever, headache, photophobia,
and neck stiffness.
Lumbar puncture usually shows
decreased glucose, increased
protein, and mononuclear
white blood cells, as well
as an increased opening
pressure. CSF India Inc. can
reveal the organisms, and
that is shown at the bottom
right. The cryptococcal
antigen titer is positive in
both cerebrospinal fluid
and in blood but it only has
prognostic value in the csf
it can be seen by mu c carmin
or methamine silver
stains in bronchial fluids
treatment is with liposomal
amphotericin b and flucytocine
followed by high dose oral
fluconazole and then followed
by indefinite oral fluconazole
prophylaxis. The top
figure shows cryptococcal
neoformans in a biopsy of
brain tissue. The middle
figure shows a slice of brain
tissue that is stained for
the capsular polysaccharide.
This is synonymous with the
antigen that is measured
in cerebrospinal fluid. you
can see how much of this
there is and that much
protein gets within the
cerebrospinal fluid and can
cause obstruction at the outlet
of the fourth ventricle at
the foramina of Lushka and
Magendi. Obstruction results
in increasing CSF pressure,
increasing intracranial
pressure, and that can alter
consciousness. That is
actually emergence and the
treatment is to relieve the
pressure by doing a ventriculostomy
to allow the CSF to flow
outside of the skull.
There are two other cerebral
opportunistic infections
that do not fall within
the differential diagnosis
of meningitis but should
be spoken about here.
The first is progressive
multifocal leukoencephalopathy.
We have mentioned this
before. This is caused
by a JCPolyoma virus. The
infection is widespread and
90% of humans are infected
with no symptoms. But
in those who are immune
suppressed, it causes a
unifocal or multifocal
cerebral demyelination disease.
Patients present with
subacute cognitive impairment,
focal motor deficits, and
seizures, and the demyelating
lesions can be seen on
brain MRI as seen on
the left in panel A. The
differential diagnosis includes
AIDS dementia complex,
CMV encephalitis, and
infarction, and the diagnosis
can be made by lumbar
puncture and obtaining
CSFJC virus nucleic acid
amplification. The treatment
is antiretroviral therapy.
There is no specific treatment
for the virus itself,
and the response to treatment
is variable with some
patients actually getting
better and some patients
having persistent deficit.
Toxoplasma gondii is
a protozoan parasitic
infection that occurs after
the ingestion of parasite
tissue cysts in raw or
undercooked meat. In the
immune-competent person, it
can be asymptomatic but may
present as seizures from
calcified cerebral cysts.
If transmission occurs
from mother to fetus. It
can result in miscarriage,
stillbirth, or congenital
toxoplasmosis, which is
characterized by abnormal
*********** or smallness
of the head. In those who
are immune suppressed,
they can present
with fever, headache,
confusion, motor
defects, and seizures.
CT shows a space
-occupying gray matter
lesion. These are in the
gray matter as opposed
to PML, which is in
the white matter.
The differential diagnosis
here includes lymphoma,
and the diagnosis can be
made by CSF toxoplasma PCR.
There's also serology
and characteristic
appearance on
pathological specimens.
Treatment is sulfadiazine
pyrimethamine
or clindamycin pyrimethamine.
Bobby has lumbar puncture
that shows a glucose of 10
mg that's low, an elevated
protein of 220, and white
blood cells of 1,200 with
80% mononuclear cells.
India ink is positive, and
cryptococcal antigen
titer is 1 to 64.
Opening pressure is
high at 22 mm of water.
liposomal amphisericin
b and flucidocine are
begun with a plan to switch
to oral fluconazole in
two weeks his headache
and meninges miss improve
discharge planning has
begun and his medications
at home will also
include trimethoprim
sulfamethoxazole
valgancyclovir azithromycin and
ethambutol when bobby asks
why he is not going home
on antiretroviral therapy
what do you tell him?
You let Bobby know that he
needs to be on medication
to treat his opportunistic
infections for a period
of time before starting
antiretroviral therapy to
prevent immune reconstitution
inflammatory syndrome. This
is an immune response that
occurs secondary to the
improvement in the immune
system when antiretrovirals
are started. There are
two types, unmasking iris
occurs secondary to undiagnosed
occult infection for
example if you did not
know that somebody had cmv
retinitis because it was
not looked for on a retinal
exam or serology and you
started antiretroviral therapy
the patient could have
an exuberant inflammatory
response in the retina that
results in blindness. There
is also paradoxical iris
that is caused by residual
antigenic stimulation from
prior infections. This
is less common. Usually
this occurs only in patients
whose CD4 count was less
than 100 before beginning
antiretroviral therapy. The
exception is tuberculosis,
which patients can have a
CD4 count as high as 200.
It occurs in up to 13% of
patients in whom ART is
started from one week
to three to four months
after the beginning of
antiretroviral therapy. The
organisms that this occurs
in are listed on the
right. This is a limited
list, but it is the most
common organisms.
prevention is to check for
these infections and treat
for at least two to four
weeks before beginning
antiretroviral therapy.
I'd like to thank you
so much for listening.
Please don't hesitate to
contact me if you have any
question either during
office hours by email or
making an appointment via
Calendly. During office
hours this week we will
go over review questions
for this lecture during
the 2 to 3 p.m. slot.
We really do value your
opinion, so please do give
us feedback on our lectures
so that we can make
them better. I hope everyone
has a wonderful day.